maybe you like photography maybe you
like videography and here it's not even
necessary to always have a big master
plan of what will come out of these
things so let's think about photography
maybe you just started as a hobby and
then spend time in the evenings
researching the topic learning about it
getting some experience in practice but
maybe then in the future you develop
this into a little side business where
you do photography for maybe weddings or
other things and this is just an
additional source of side income that
you really enjoy doing or maybe by
learning about the photography industry
you suddenly have a business idea an
idea for a startup that you can now
develop that now you can get yourself
into